[Music]
so
and we're live
hey hey
look at this hey it's stephen rodgers oh
my gosh
he's so famous
yes
how do you feel man you just you just
dropped the special do you feel relief
do you feel what what's what's going
through your your mind right now
uh relief now
uh
that like people seem to like it
[Music]
but uh yeah relief
in the fact that like
you're holding on to this thing you
gotta make sure it's you're you know uh
the editing the uh
the thank yous were more stressful than
i thought they were gonna be just making
sure i you put a lot of people on them i
saw you're like i'm doing everyone
i i got to the point where they're like
hey these are too many so i just put
anyone that's ever booked me that way
covered comedians i i should have just
put anyone that's uh liked comedy once
and then that would have covered more
but yeah relief that it's out relates
that people uh like it and uh
relief uh like we were kind of talking
about before uh
that really that there's a bar i've set
for myself now that i have to
uh
eat meat but hopefully uh surpass for
sure for sure
i
like the challenge
yeah and 503 dude is already in here
saying aloha y'all good to see you buddy
hello as people are coming in here on
the live stream but this is this is just
so exciting because
we met during the pandemic when um we
really started all this online stuff
with the hot breath verse and you were
talking about doing an album
and just like trying to like you're like
i don't know how i'm gonna do it but i
want to and i was like oh we should
document this so we've kind of right we
did two podcasts yeah and video as well
but yeah we did two interviews of like
your attempts and your ideas and then
what worked and what didn't work like i
listened back to him today and they were
like both of them were like well i tried
this and it didn't work or i tried to
record here and then uh i didn't hit it
didn't actually record
and then like so many different things
which i think is cool for
people to see that you know you'd at
that point you'd been on colbert you're
opening up for brian regan so i think a
lot of comedians see you
and comedians at that higher level who
are like oh they have it all figured out
and it all just happens magically for
them but at every level we're all trying
to figure it out as we go
yes 100
and and uh
it was uh
i what i figured out was i can't do it
alone
um i have no technology
technology abilities whatsoever
um
i i'm friends with tony deo who's a
really talented comedian but also
has taught himself on like sound
engineering and stuff
so he was trying to talk me through it
in a time where you weren't allowed to
see each other in person
so he's like yeah hit this thing and
then you hit this thing and then you'll
have an amazing sounding album and never
did it work once
uh
that was basically the first uh hurdle
and then um
uh i met
some of the folks uh well i met the
people that do the uh album label blonde
medicine i saw that i hadn't heard of
them before but they've done a lot
they're very they're
i mean they're incredible i can't say
enough nice things about them uh
and uh just jessica and dom are the main
uh people there that uh
did so much for me and they've made a
lot of good albums like irene two's
album that just came out uh sam evans
a couple mike kaplans and um there's so
many out like nori davis there's a lot
of good albums on there
uh and i got lucky that they liked me
and wanted to work with me and
liked the jamestown vision that i had
and
uh it just sort of worked out uh so all
those mistakes
leading up to this
uh i'm glad those happen because what
hap we ended up making i'm very uh
excited about
yeah because even i remember in the
first interview we did you were talking
about how maybe your next one you'll
work with a label but you're like this
one i really just want to do
on my own and then you got into the
logistics of it and all that said it it
turned out great though dude whatever
yeah whatever yeah it turned out amazing
well all the credit goes to
pretty much uh
all of them i mean
i i didn't know what i was thinking uh
as far as trying to do it myself it was
too much stress
and uh
they uh are experts at what they do
because all i had to worry about was the
material and that's uh
what you should be focused on exactly uh
yeah and uh that
i would i think i was just uh
being too stubborn in the beginning
being like i can do this all myself
because you know you're in a pandemic
everything was halted i was like i can't
wait
and i think i was just trying to grab on
to something during a stressful time for
everybody we yeah we all were yeah yeah
uh so uh i'm glad that i it went the way
it did i'm very uh i love uh jessica and
dom at blonde medicine and
uh very very happy with the album and
special yeah they were there when you
did cordon last night
they were with you there how did you
because you've always talked about how
you've always booked everything without
any like agent or manager how did the
cordon thing come to be
same
uh thing
all me
uh
i just uh
you know i love late night's my favorite
thing in the world and uh
i felt like i had a
a window of opportunity plugging uh
album
being like
well this is a really good reason to
have me on the show
as i'm promoting something
and uh
so i put a tape together of stuff i
really liked and um
it was uh
pretty well liked by the corden booker
and it didn't take too much
uh time we had to play around with some
stuff but uh
uh yeah that was all me thankfully wow
yeah congrats man i love hearing that
yeah
yeah yeah and it was
truly another amazing experience the
everyone at the late late show was
fantastic and i had the best time
yeah
bob jorgensen said yeah congrats on the
special in the late late show now follow
me back on twitter you elite snob
oh okay great uh that that will no way
to follow you i've gotten several i
didn't realize how big of a deal it was
but i've it's lately i've actually
gotten several dms from people who are
like so when you follow me back and i
was like i didn't realize this was a
thing but okay
i didn't either personally
yeah i didn't know it was a thing people
get pretty crazy about it um
i i i have a hard time following
uh
i'm also like it's such a weird thing
i'm trying to talk about this in
stand-up but like
i'm trying to be someone that's in the
moment and uh with people and in person
okay if you like right now you have 100
of my attention
and no one on my phone is getting any
and for some reason the people that are
contacting me through my phone will be
upset by that yes
for sure it's crazy to me when it's like
i i'm
a great in person thing technology i i
come off like a jerk just because i'm
trying to be on it less
it's uh because you're taking care of
yourself how selfish
i know i know
how dare i be a a human
bonds with other human beings
uh but yeah some of my best friends uh
even when i did the uh out when the
album came out they said hey check out
his album uh but he's a bad texter
yeah that's so cool it was interesting
because i think
um one of the hop brother and i think
dino said you live in the same building
as renowned hershberg and joe list
and you all three released a special
recently
yes uh so our building is joelis sarah
talamash
uh caitlyn paluffo renon hirschberg and
myself oh my gosh
yeah like national lampoons dude that's
awesome yeah i don't know if you guys
have ever uh been uh
like
worried about following your neighbors
on
if i bomb in front of any of those
people i gotta hear it when i'm at the
mailbox
you guys don't have to deal with that
it's crazy but you could forever make
fun of uh that sign on joe list special
have you watched it again
i was there i was there that him opening
about the sign was a mistake it was just
like this huge
we tried caitlyn and i tried to see if
we could fit it in the car to drive it
home for him oh really
yeah it did not it was huge
it was so big
uh i don't even think we didn't it
didn't leave the building i i think it's
i don't think it's still there i think
it's been thrown out honestly i don't
really
i don't know what happened to it
that was hilarious it was in our
backyard and we just
on it but um yeah and then uh
i was at ronan's latest special taping
which i think that comes out in
hopefully later this year which is
really good and then
i was at his uh tonight show as well so
everybody in this building except for
one person
uh who's not a comedian has late night
credits hilarious it's a crazy apartment
phone
so so to get into the special a little
bit here and we have people
uh tuning in ricardo said hey guys hope
you're well
and uh sandy bernstein said congrats
stephen rodgers
thank you emre congrats stevens sketch
my story what an amazing experience oh
that's great yeah
how exciting so to to get into your
actual special
um you you mentioned you referred to the
jamestown vision so i mean the fact
that you even filmed this dude at the
national comedy center i mean that that
was a huge i was like oh that like adds
a whole other like cachet to it so you
said the jamestown vision so how did
it went from an album you're gonna
record yourself to now this like
big comedy special at the national
comedy center so where how did you what
was the vision behind it
um
so i think we've talked about this
before
both regan
and
colbert
came from
uh jamestown
uh both
brian and the booker of of colbert at
different times saw me
in that room that the specials taped in
and uh
so and anthony devito is a good friend
of mine
i i you know you when you're doing
anything you know this you i mean that's
what this is built upon you're asking
other comics
for advice when you're doing something
and i remember anthony devito said uh
that he was told you want to book your
your you want to record your first uh
thing at some place that means a lot to
you
and uh which i'm sure is the case for
you i think it was in it was in atlanta
right yeah it was in the it was in the
first venue that ever booked me as a
headliner the basement right you're here
exactly so it's like you want to do you
want to have that little
uh specialness trap uh connected to it
and uh
so i was like well there's no other
place that
uh meant as much
and brought as much into my life as as
this place
and uh they were very excited about it
and oh that's great at
the national comedy center
and uh blonde medicine really liked the
idea
and it just kind of worked out perfectly
uh caitlyn was able to be there and and
uh
ej mossy campo was there from breath who
i met through here and
uh another good friend of mine peter
wong
who's a new york comic one of the like
first friends i made in new york so i i
just
i wanted it to be a big special hang um
and i wanted to
uh also pay a little tribute to what
lucy fest has done for uh jamestown and
i call it so many things but at uh
national comedy center lucyfest
jamestown they're all the same yeah and
uh i wanted to uh pay tribute to all
that stuff so
uh it was it was cool it was a cool
experience
how thought out was the actual because
you said the jamestown vision so
did you think as far as like i want to
open with a skit and then like these are
the shots like how thought out was that
whole part of it
i know i knew i wanted to show some of
the center
um
i wanted people to know this national
comedy center exists yeah and
uh that it's cool like there's stuff in
there
um
like
that's a
tribute to stand and comedy in general
um i didn't know i was gonna do a sketch
but i was able to
have some people that make me feel funny
around and i'm like yeah let's
let's be goofy and see if there's
something here and
uh
and then as far as like i knew i wanted
it to be in that room i wanted it to be
three cameras i wanted it
to um
uh
showcase what i do and also showcase
this place so it was um
i had a lot of talented people behind it
chris walsh
uh who did all the video and his team
uh they were they were awesome and
everybody was on the same page so
if i didn't know what i was trying to
say thankfully there was much more
knowledge and talented people to fill in
those gaps
and how many times did you film it
we did four shows because that's the
typical
weekend at that venue
okay
and uh they were all sold out which was
kind of cool and uh
yeah it was it was fun and i liked doing
it in a small town
instead of being like live from you know
a place that many many specials are made
like
i i wanted it i liked that and it's up
sort of upstate new york it's western
new york but
in ties into where i'm i started
that's so funny that you recorded it
four times and you decided to leave in
some of the
the the hiccups and stuff which i really
appreciated and i did that with i forgot
my jokes during my special and i left
the i left that part in so it's like i
think that's
that's what uh
is
i don't know i think for me and and i
like that you did that too
and any special i've seen that's done
that
i can't think of any off the top of my
head i know some people that have
removed stuff but joe's good example
mentioning the sign behind him
you know it's like
how uh
i don't know i i strong i have a strong
belief and this is just my opinion
nobody wants to see a comedian that's
not really there hmm
so it's like
uh
i need people to see proof that i'm in
the moment instead of on twitter
following people back i'm in uh
[Laughter]
you know what i mean
yes
you are getting a hundred percent of me
and if i make a mistake guess what i'm
gonna make that funny too or i'm gonna
try i'm gonna try
i'm not gonna
leave something on the table
and uh
when that therapy thing happened in the
special
uh
it was funny it was funny that i messed
up and
made up for it and when a woman
corrected a setup that i've been saying
for years
uh
and
and pointed out something i never
noticed yeah i'm not too proud to
uh keep that from everyone
uh or would i not too proud to show that
i messed up or you know what i mean of
course i wish she was here to yell out
what i'm trying to say
[Laughter]
and i think there's a couple other
things and then in the credits i
included the rest
of stuff that happened
as long as it doesn't like
ruin the joke
uh
i'm i'm willing to have it in there at
least in that experience
i think that was like i knew you were
funny and i knew you were a great writer
but i think
getting to see you do your special i
think the most pleasant surprise
was how loose it was because you're very
meticulous with your writing and you're
very specific
with like how you perform but it was
very loose like you you were very
physical you were all you were kind of
all over the stage you even went behind
the podium at one point like it felt
very loose and spontaneous which is
something i knew it was going to be
hilarious but i didn't expect it to feel
so loose
just knowing your comedy before so that
makes me also excited for like
now that you're you're kind of moved to
the next chapter of your career like i
feel like there's a lot of physicality
to you to your stand-up that we're gonna
start seeing more of maybe i'm
projecting on you but it just seemed
like it was it was just like more anime
than i expected it was pleasantly i say
pleasantly surprised that's i'm honored
that
i thank you for saying that i i mean it
has already increased
um
i mean i have a really good
mentor
uh that i watch regularly that is the
most physical comedian
you know we've seen so far in the
history of comedy and
i'm not trying at all
to be him but it he
brian showed me brian regan in case
oh just a little yeah he's a little flex
just look sir
[Music]
yeah yeah uh
if that helps he doesn't follow me
uh
that's that's like chattering in your
brain the rest of this time not fast
that's all i can think about somebody
somebody immediately calling me out i'm
like i'm a jerk i know i gotta talk
people love you dude no worries i know
i'm teasing um
but uh
through that and other watching other
comedians uh like jim carrey or
um
that's more of a like a film thing but
like there's so many comics that get
there
once i started looking at physicality as
a second punch line
uh
that's when i was like well then i
should be
moving
um
and showing
showing what you're telling
uh when i started to learn that and see
that how many more laughs
uh people are getting by doing both how
much you're leaving on the table by not
adding the movements
because you can paint a picture with
your words
uh for example on the uh the pray joke
uh
i want uh strong women you go after what
you want so i would just go to a bar and
try to look like prey that's funny
but if i
show them
that also that's a second
laugh
so why wouldn't i
grabbed both yeah
so
uh
yeah speaking of physicality
i did want to bring in one of the clips
from the special to give people a little
taste speaking of physicality and um
emre said what are you drinking
oh this is teeth i got from um
the swag bag in corydon
yeah yeah i i uh
like i was telling you before i was
sleepy today so i was like i'm gonna try
this tea so lovely
yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah sketch my story said
cool set yeah yeah it's a beautiful
beautiful room uh yeah special shot
beautiful also yeah
they they haven't shot anything like
this there before
and because of this and how talented the
um
uh chris and his team are with filming
and lighting and all that the event the
national community center said they're
probably going to keep this lighting
for future uh shows and stuff wow
it was cool too first dude
yeah it was cool to uh
be a part of that
so let's um let's show an example of
this physicality from the special
um it just so happened
we talked about physicality and then
this is the clip i chose so here here's
a here's a fun clip
and then i would um i'd like to kind of
get your feedback on how you developed
this because this is like a this is like
a big part of your of your special
and i believe this is this is also the
joke i think you end your cordon set on
as well so it's clearly one you've
worked out a lot so um let's give the
people a taste here
steven rogers before he was super
my relationship's great i only have one
problem in my relationship is uh anytime
my girlfriend sends me to go get
something i can never find it
yeah
i just sensed how many fights i just
started
like any time my girlfriend like she
thinks i'm not trying but really i'm
standing in front of that cabinet like
come on eyes
you ever try to make them bigger
thinking that you'll see more stuff
come on eyes
i'll put you on whatever your websites
you want just
for the love of god find it
she sends me the store i'll send her
pictures of what i'm looking at to see
if it's the right thing
i'm like is this it is this it is this
it she's like yeah that's the store
please go in
[Laughter]
if i go to the store and they don't have
what she sent me to go get i sent her a
video of the manager telling her that i
looked
[Laughter]
i'm like you tell her i looked
you tell her
now hold up today's paper
you guys
all right
so that's a physical bit
yeah and it kills
so like
it's definitely one where you're telling
and showing
you know you could just say i tell her
the man tell the manager or whatever
like but like so how this is clearly you
in the special on it so it's like
how did this it's all based in reality
so like how did you kind of like develop
this bit
um
it was a real you know obviously it just
comes from a real place it was a real
problem that we were having
that
she would
want something i could never find it and
i remember sending her pictures at the
store
and being like this what am i doing this
is ridiculous that i i'm that worried
about coming back empty-handed
and um
so i was excited about that joke and
once i think i tweeted it and and like
some comedians were like this is
something
and um
so that was nice and then i started i
think it started with um
the uh the pictures it started with the
pictures it uh so the center of that bit
the is this is this it
and uh
i think i was just telling people yeah
when i'm at the store i send her
pictures of to see if it's the right
thing and
and then i remember
i really wanted to get across how
desperate i am and that's where the uh
the cabinet came from
and then
uh i
just i really wanted to get the
desperateness across in the words and
then eventually i know the words came
first
and then i was like
well all of these are things
that i can also show
so i remember
doing the command eyes thing and that
was killing
at like theaters and stuff and i was
like okay there's something here and
then i think the last thing i found
was the
you know you tell her i look thing
and i remember loving
[__] like pointing it like almost like a
gun just being like you have to do this
i re i i liked showing the desperateness
physically
and then the you ever make your eyes
bigger
thing
um i i don't want to
give credit
i don't want to forget anyone so i had
in my green room on in on the shows was
peter wong caitlyn palufo and ej
and one of them or all together we came
up with
what if you made your eyes bigger
and uh so that part came
that
recording that
came
for the album oh wow
yeah so that ever make your eyes bigger
thinking you'll see more stuff i've
never said that before
by the time that recording was happening
wow
yeah and uh so all i had was come on
eyes
is this and i loved
going around
it was just fun it was like how can i
and once i realized how relatable it was
that was the closer so it made me have
to be more physical to
really
be like this is the
what we're ending on so we gotta end
strong here
um
and
yeah so that's and then
with even with cordon i did it on cordon
and
i did it a little faster which i liked
it added more desperateness to it but uh
that's something you only see in
hindsight but uh
yeah i liked i wanted that emotion to
come across physically
yeah that's something you mentioned in
one of our previous interviews was like
you want to make sure you're matching
the emotion
of the joke
with like it all has to come from the
emotion and the writing must express
that emotion the performance must
express that emotion so it's kind of
like you had this
this real life situation
that does make you feel desperate so
you're like okay however i tag this up
whatever act outs i do must express
this desperation and it must
re-emphasize the desperation i'm trying
to get across
right
cool
yeah uh
that's pretty much every
joke i'm sure there's exceptions
but the emotion is
why i want to talk about it you know so
uh
this is our own this is our bigger
biggest problem
in the relationship and yes it's my
fault
uh and here's
me trying to do my best
in these three examples so all of your
jokes
or like let me because we walk around
all day thinking of jokes and stuff so
yeah when you have an idea
you're like okay what is the emotion
behind this and then you kind of build
it out from there
i
i think i read this or heard this
somewhere somebody said
if your mood changes
whenever you're you know your mood
changes x amount of times a day it's
like a
there's a study on it or something but
uh
when your mood changes there's probably
something there it was a writer that
said yeah like
throughout the day when your mood
changes there's probably something there
um
so going to the store
uh
confident and then realizing they don't
have what she
wants and uh god i'm gonna have to go
home and tell her i really did look
she's not gonna believe me
and all that like that feeling
is something
and then i i start with the i think i
start with the feeling
usually the feeling
i'm like
almost like just getting it off your
chest or you know we're all complainers
so it's like um
i'll try to do a different joke for
example
but like um
uh the um
the rub the opener on the cord and the
rubbing the leg thing
like uh i can never tell when a woman
likes me yeah
uh i'm so
clueless and like how clueless
would i get and i bet you you know what
i mean yeah
um just kind of moaned right there i
don't know what that was he like said
that i was like oh
clueless yeah hey but that's interesting
i like the first time for everything
yeah
that is that really makes me want to
like start attempting to like write that
way because i usually am like
as of right now it is still like
this happened or here's an idea okay how
can i i still try to over like clever
i still try to like over clever the
funny and be like well what's the funny
word play here or whatever instead of
like well how am i feeling about this
and how can i reinforce that through
tags and through act outs you know i
still hide behind
the writing sometimes but starting with
the emotion and letting that drive how
you write the joke yeah that that's that
sounds like a game changer there
well like i remember reading
this too like
there's four major emotions you can
apply
uh which is weird
uh hard scary and stupid
um
so like uh
i just did cordon so i'm using those
jokes as an example of course yeah easy
for people to reference as well yeah but
like the um
i was nervous about meeting my buddy my
my girlfriend's parents
and my buddy was like just focus on how
her mom looks
now
uh that
expression i we've all heard it
and um if you know it's a common thing
i've heard throughout my life
i think that's stupid
and uh
so it's like well what's
uh and the word play came
along later i mean that is the whole
joke is just wordplay but like um
it's stupid that we focus on that and
and uh i don't that's stupid advice also
so it's like there's that's how i feel
towards this
this side this uh expression is it's not
helpful
uh it is
stupid advice
and uh how could uh
this uh
also be i don't know the the punch line
i just remember
coming from
me thinking about the the
the advice a lot
but there's an example of stupid like
uh also it's
stupid how often
uh
like
i think it's stupid that you have to be
more like you have to be super masculine
as a man you have to be super masculine
well my girlfriend is a former athlete
and is this and this and it's like
i'm not
so
i think it's stupid that that's the the
stereotypes that we have to be in as men
and women
so what's a way to
poke at that it's my girlfriend makes me
feel pretty
yeah like uh
that's turning it on its head a little
bit i'm it
now none of this is
a lot of this is by accident i'm just
going by like
this is how i feel i'm just leading the
emotion is kind of carrying me through
the writing
and there's a lot of writing
in my notebook that's just like
whining and complaining because i'm
leading with emotion so i do have to go
through it and be like nobody wants to
hear this this is
just me whining and then oh this is
something so it's just like scanning it
later
or during
uh for something that i think would be
fun to say
and uh play with
so you do more journaling
i don't do free writing anymore it it uh
was making me
angry and anxious i'm like i'm just
spilling out crap huh but if i if i um
set a timer for an hour
and just sit there and it's like the
seinfeld method you can't do anything
else
yeah
um
but sit there and and look at the paper
and the ideas and i have uh
a doc of um
i think i've mentioned this before what
i consider the hour
and um
and then i have another doc of jokes i
wanna say and i have another doc of
jokes that i haven't tried or jokes that
um
need a lot of work
and i'll set a timer and
and
scan through those or i'll sit set a
timer and sit there and write
so there's a lot of journaling and then
there's a lot of
rereading
uh because i recently remember
like
all the advice is cliche with
like stand up there's so much cliche
advice but it's because it's true yeah
um
like whatever the percentages of it is
rewriting i forgot all about rewriting
and was like
uh that's how it came out the first time
that's got to be that way and uh that's
stubborn and dumb
of me
and uh so i've been rewriting a lot
lately and
uh
always doing something that as long as
i'm trying to be less hard on myself and
just be like did you do something today
that's gonna help the material
good job and then uh
on to the next thing
yeah i i had to like lower the bar for
myself because i was getting at a point
of it's like okay i started this right
10 club we do this every day and if i'm
not doing it then i'm not being like a
good example or whatever or if like if
i'm not doing x y and z and i i
literally
now a lot of the times right now i'm
going through just like journaling like
i'm not even like specifically trying to
do anything funny i literally like set a
i do a 20 minute timer and the goal is
to do
three of those cycles but if the timer
goes off and like i i need to step away
or whatever it's like i just follow that
impulse because
it is an accumulation of just the
repetition of doing it but a lot of the
times if we don't feel like we're
creating something sometimes reading old
jokes and trying to rework stuff doesn't
feel like we're writing for some reason
in my head but it's it's can be just as
if not more productive to refine what
you have instead of always trying to
just make believe new things
yeah i think it's like um
that's why i have the three docs it's
like
um
what's standing out to me today if i
look through the
the stuff i'm telling on the road and
nothing pops out at me like i this is
another emotion thing
if not if i have no desire to play with
any of that stuff it's got to be playing
in my mind
yeah yeah
uh
it is a i wouldn't say it's a qual it's
a quality that works for me but
i'm
it only works in stand-up um
i have to find a way to play with
finances but uh i haven't figured that
out yet
but um
what do i want to play with so i look at
the
the hour and if nothing stands out
that's fine and then i look at the stuff
i want to say that one i usually have
the most fun with because it's
that one's super led by emotion it's
like even if the laughs aren't happening
with this yet there's something about
this i really want to say
and i believe in and then there's the
the miscellaneous pile of
looking through it's almost like a two
chests full of toys and it's like what
do i
you know um or three i'm sorry
um
but uh
and then i play with those things for an
hour
and and i do that in the morning because
uh
the rest of the day i feel like a writer
i have writer's brain because i did it
first thing in the morning probably
learned it from
tuning in every morning with you
and then uh
you know what i mean like you you do it
up early yeah and then
even if i have zero results the rest of
that day that muscle is warmed up
and uh
maybe i say something when i'm goofing
around with my friends
or
something bubbles up and
uh
on stage or
when i'm walking around
so yeah that's beautiful yeah right ten
club
helped stephen do his comedy special
everyone so take a note
join the facebook page already yeah
right yeah been working on this material
for eight years but yeah the right ten
club did it yeah yeah yeah
yeah in our previous interview you had
you had all the note cards on your wall
color coordinated based on topic like
you had this whole thing like mapped out
to like the breath
yeah and uh now i i i forget to breathe
a lot so it's
hot breath
uh oh drew beekler
he's he's a comic up in new york have
you met him before
drew b i probably have i'm either a name
or a face it's such a bad quality with
me it's all he didn't say anything about
you not following him or anything don't
worry i just know he's up in new york as
well good start no worries
his uh his question was would you say
it's how do i feel about whatever topic
and then exaggerating details on the
topic to back up that feeling you have
that's a good
question um i'm gonna
let's see
well i'm talking about being bad at
texting
uh
on this new thing i'm working on
and
so yeah i'm that's the quality like
that's the thing that's popping up is
people saying i'm bad i'm bad at texting
so and then there's the emotion of well
how you know defensiveness because
you're you and it but also like how do i
feel about texting why am i bad at
it so i am
i think
yeah i guess so i that's a great
question i've never thought of it that
way
um sometimes i'll do a wheel
i'll put the the topic in the center of
the page and then whatever
feelings and
things i think are related to it i'll
you know branch off
uh i tried a little bit of everything
i think i have one right here hold on
yeah yeah
hold on let me see if i can um
as you're pulling that up let me see if
i can uh
pull you up here in the middle we'll
give you the big screen if you're about
to
i love this each of the interviews we've
done you've gone to your notebook and
like shown us specific yeah um examples
oh and drew um he also produces the show
big wave in new york as well oh i know
drew hey drew yeah i'm sorry i'm so bad
with it's one or the other it's all good
yeah
let's see here
i guess this is the best one but it's
the joke still needs
work of course yeah these are all new
things you're like yeah so this is uh oh
let me see here
there you go yeah so
i uh
i i was held back in the second grade
and uh so that's
i put that in the center i'm gonna have
to pull it away to remember yeah no
problem
so then it's like
i tried branching off with thing the
first things i thought of when it came
to second grade
but um
so like teacher came up
right there
and then after teacher came uh a real
feeling which was
when i
failed
second grade the second year of second
grade
on the first day
uh
[Music]
my
original second grade teacher dropped by
the class so i'm in with my second
class and my first teacher comes by to
visit
and i remember being feeling embarrassed
because she knew
that i failed second grade but nobody
else there did
so i
pretended to be there helping
uh
like i was visiting from third grade for
some reason right
so
there's a stupid thing that i did out of
embarrassment
that fooled no one
and it's like well there's something
like that's fun to tell like at a
party or whatever like that's a funny
thing so it's like
well there's something there and now
i'll put it down and
and now try to
add punchlines because uh sometimes i
i've seen some stand-up where it's like
you just tell the thing that happened
but it's like i
still want punch lines in there that are
written
uh
i wanna know how i'm gonna say it and
that kind of stuff but that's like so
that's just me branching off uh
one
topic and then there's probably emotions
all over the place but then little
uh oh yeah so i got held back for being
too immature
i don't know if this is there we go yeah
that's
too immature and then i put
but what do those poopoo heads think
that's
it's
stupid um but
uh oh wait what are those poop heads now
um
uh
it's like how do you start to put all
this into like do you just kind of go
each like path like you're kind of like
all right let me talk about the teacher
moment let me
do the poopoo headlines you kind of just
brainstorm a bunch of this stuff and
then try each of them out on stage
yeah this i haven't
this one i'm afraid to bring to the
stage at the moment
um
uh because i feel like it's not i don't
have enough
of an idea of where
things
go um
but uh when i do the map
it's
no plan
in place
no direction i try not to be neat i try
not to have a shape in mind for the map
it's just like
uh you failed second grade go and then
oh okay uh what's in second grade the
teacher
oh yeah that time that
teacher came by
uh what else happens in second grade i
had oh i the main feeling i have on
there is failure
[Music]
and
it's like yeah
i fail i feel like a failure because i
failed second grade
and then i wrote i learned failure
before i knew how to spell it
so it's like that might not be something
i have in the joke but it's like
uh
it's a good exercise
so um that's one way i
i try to look at things differently but
maybe that's why you got held back as
well because you couldn't spell failure
yes
i uh the poo poo head it almost feels
like a joke there though of like you
know it you got held back from second
grade for being too immature but what
are those poo poo heads no like that
almost right there feels like
okay there's one punch line for this
entire idea you know
yeah
just spitballing though you know oh yeah
like that one i'm like that i'll
probably say
um and it's fun and silly
yeah
um oh i had perfect attendance but i was
never really there
uh
so it's like there's
nets off of me just writing attendance
so i think i
when i'm looking at this trying to study
this i take
the topic and then i take the first
thing i think about off that topic but
then
truth follows that
so it's like second grade i think of
a
teacher and then what's true things that
i feel or happened or think about
teachers
um one thing that's not in here but
is in the joke is
my girlfriend's mom is a second grade
teacher
and
so that's just like gold
as far as like there's something there
that the bell goes off there uh-huh and
then the joke right now is my
girlfriend's mom is a second grade
teacher and i'm worried she's gonna find
out and start randomly bringing up the
curriculum
and uh
so it's yeah that's good to spell
failure yeah
yeah so i had like this never worked but
she was like do you know about roy g biv
and
i go is that one of her ex-boyfriends
[Laughter]
um
it's stuff like that so
mainly having fun just
um
my pros this wasn't the question but my
process with it is like
emotions and fun
yeah i i'm trying to lead more with fun
too i think what really changed
my mindset around that i
um i recently had jeremiah watkins back
on the show and he just had a kid
he just had a kid and i was like how did
it change your mentality because i hear
you change when you have a kid and he
was basically like i'm at a point now
where i don't want to
do anything or write anything or create
anything or be around people unless it's
fun like he only he only surrounds
himself
and goes with the intention of he's
going to have fun or if something's
going to give him energy he's like
that's where his mind is at now he leads
with fun and that really i just talked
to him a few weeks ago but that really
affected kind of my approach to
everything i'm doing now as well
well it's like um
i'm not
old
in comparison to life uh expectancy but
i
i don't know what it is if i'm just an
old soul or whatever but i was like ah
life's too short i'm i'm not gonna drive
myself crazy anymore
uh i'm going to try to be creative but
i'm not going to put the this cage
around it uh you have to do it at this
time to this time you have to do this
you have to do this and then you're
that's the only way you're a comedian
and it's like um
that stuff is not gonna be fun
uh to hear if it was built in a
uh
you know if it if i become a machine by
having a machine like
uh structure to everything but if i
keep my day loose
like i have two
calves
that yeah you just got another one i
heard caitlyn talking about the new one
on uh are you garbage podcast talking
about the whole process of getting that
cat and everything yeah
so i'm talking about that in the new
uh
headlining set
there's one right there
yeah so
they're my world if they want to play
that's
my day now like i have to play with them
until they're done
because like my guiltyness won't let me
sit and write
and that in a way has made it so it's
like oh i write
in different ways i write when i'm
sitting and playing i write when i'm
walking
uh if they're asleep i'll sit and write
so it's like there's no set time anymore
i like to do it in the morning
but
it's loose and because of that my stand
up is more loose my
um writing is more loose or i feel more
loose i guess so it's um
and that's more fun i'm just trying to
uh also live my life
is uh yeah
i'm realizing
i wasn't uh
for a good amount of time and now i'm
like let's live life and uh get material
that way
oh dude i wasn't living until
probably the pandemic like before the
pandemic you know i'd been doing comedy
10 years and literally like nothing like
eat sleep and breathe comedy every night
like always pre pandemic i was about to
be on the road more than ever and i'm
grateful now i was actually had that
opportunity to step back and really
reassess priorities and now i'm like
i'm saying no to some gigs yeah that are
like eight hours away that i would have
like jumped on yeah i'll do it for a
hundred dollars or whatever but now it's
like well let you know there's more
perspective i guess so it really makes a
big difference in your productivity as
well
yeah
i am
yeah i'm having more fun like i have
some bits
that are doing well but
boy were they only brought to the stage
because i wanted to say them
you know i i have a thing
about peacocks
that no one
needs to hear
uh but i
love it
and
therefore
i'm in a place of play
it's a good joke but it's like
um
i i'm not trying to change the world
with my stand up just everybody's moods
including my own oh i love that
yeah
uh
so this peacock joke makes me feel good
i hope you guys feel good too but uh i'm
telling it either way it's like that's
uh
i don't know what i'm saying with that
but that's just seems to be where i am
right now i love that man wow
there was wow that was the biggest thing
that i think shined through
in the special was just how much fun you
were having like yeah it really
i mean when i did mine like i was like
very like stiff and like i gotta get
through and that's why i forgot i've
been doing these jokes for years but i
forgot it during the taping because i
was literally putting so much pressure
on every syllable has to be here because
i told stand-up comedy works and it like
it it really it really inspired me
seeing how much fun you were having and
just yeah just no knowing what i know
about you and how we've got to know each
other it's just you being able to just
live in that moment and have fun with it
was really inspiring and i hope other
comedians and people see that and they
get that mood change that you're
referring to
yeah i mean i now even when i watch that
clip like
i feel like it was it was
i was loose that night but i think that
was just the beginning
of loose for me
um
i uh
because even watching it now i'm like i
would have
i would have been more i would have been
quicker with it i would have been looser
with it
and it was but it's like
you know hindsight being what it is you
ended on an applause break i think you
got it
right but we're always going to be our
worst critics right that's true but uh
i like where i'm headed
um
with it i i
i want to i want to be somebody that
people want to go see live
so
uh what do i want to see
and i like
i like it when someone's there
and they're not reading off a prompter
in their brain
um
and can live with a mistake in a joke
and it doesn't throw them
uh gary shandling
is a big example of that uh
there's so many but uh joelis cordon
if if you watch that there's a part
where he gets an applause break and he
you could he's so nervous he claps
with them
and and then he calls himself out on it
and it's like
you
you could have not mentioned it and
maybe not anyone would have noticed or
you know it would only have made it in
the comments it wouldn't have thrown
your set
but he calls himself out on it and it
gets a laugh and it's like
yeah you're a human being be a human
being that does stand up
uh
stand up does not make you better than
anybody i don't think i'm better than
anybody but it's like
uh just do my favorite thing
and
it doesn't have to be perfect i mean i'm
trying to
have it be perfect but uh
everything is welcome
i think there's like a
a buddhist
saying i've heard where it's like
i will eat it all
meaning the good and the bad i'll take
everything that comes
and uh
i i don't know i that's how i prefer to
do stand-up
yeah that's what we talked about in the
last interview is radical acceptance as
well yes
yes i remember oh yeah
so very important
so where um where what what please
promote
um whatever you'd like to promote i mean
clearly the special on your youtube
channel but how can people yeah check
out everything you have going on because
this this kid's got it people this kid's
he's got the goods
i appreciate it uh i am
you just go to stephenrodgerscomedy.com
i'm actually headlining my home club
uh syracuse funny bone june 24th and
25th
uh so if you happen to be in upstate new
york
um also be at the albany funny bone
uh july 15th and 16th but uh
yeah i'm starting to get some headlining
stuff which is cool oh
congrats man that's that's that that
that hour it's it's a it's a whole new
world when like you're like that yeah
the act and it's like there's a lot more
it's more fun though you have that time
to play with
yeah i'm i'm so excited about building
the next thing and
so come come see me please say hello uh
especially if you're a comic a hot
breath person i'd love to say hello yeah
uh but yeah stephenrodgerscomedy.com
steven rogers comedy on instagram uh
and yeah check out the special please
it's uh good
it's on youtube and you have a podcast
panic attacking podcast
thank you you just saved me a divorce
uh andrew travone he's amazing he's so
funny uh check out his stand up as well
um
but uh yeah every monday panic attacking
podcast it's really funny
and did you pick your outfit for your
special
uh
uh caitlyn did most of the work
um but i think i picked the jacket but
we were together when we picked it so no
i will say no
uh i didn't pick the cordon look and i
didn't pick the special look all of that
was katelyn
yeah
well it's it's it's such a thrill i'm so
glad we got to meet each other and uh
likewise build this relationship man i'm
a big fan and i learn something every
time i watch your comedy or
hear you uh hear you speak about it so
thank you it's mutual like i was saying
i i listen and uh some i some i listen
to
i come back and listen to so it's
you're doing a great thing man you're uh
we're all learning from each other it's
really awesome thank you so much very
nice
well hop read the verse
that is all we have we're gonna land
this plane thank you so much steven for
your time thank you everyone for hanging
out
and we'll see on the other side bye
y'all